sinon ça vous avec frédéric boccara
économiste membre des économistes
atterrés philippe muray est également
économiste bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte france
philippe muray ce que cet accord va
permettre de résoudre le problème de
l'évasion fiscale
non c'est un peu de la poudre aux yeux
un très clairement cet accord qui
hantent envoyés par des gouvernements
qui connaissent cette injustice fiscale
et qui veut faire qui veulent faire
semblant de la résoudre
a priori ça rapportera 4 milliards
d'euros sur une évasion fiscale
française qui est ce qui met
généralement à 80 milliards d'euros de
fraude fiscale dont 5 5% de la fraude
fiscale qui devrait être enlevée sachant
que il faut quand même voir le contexte
le travail est axé à 45 % de taux
marginal en france alors que déjà les
entreprises seront taxées à 28% donc
beaucoup moins c'est pareil aux états
unis pour savoir qu'avant dans les
années 70 80 et bien et même dans les
années avant les entreprises étaient
taxés à 50% en france et aux états unis
ce qui était à peu près la même chose
que le travail non seulement elles sont
légalement - taxer les entreprises et il
y à des multinationales qui font une
fraude fiscale qui est assez incroyable
et assez honteuse puisque c'est quand
même du vol d'argent public qu'est ce
que vous pensez frédéric boccara de ce
taux de 15% est ce que c'est suffisant
est ce que vous considérez que c'est un
premier pas avant d'aller plus loin
alors c'est un rideau de fumée c'était
évident que c'est un rideau de fumée qui
montrent que nos gouvernants ont compris
a quelques cheveux très importante qui
se joue mais c'est un rideau de fumée
d'abord quand on annonce un taux ça veut
pas dire grand chose parce que ça dépend
de l'assiette sur laquelle s'applique
par exemple en france on annonce un taux
facial d'impôts sur les bénéfices de 31
%
et quand on rapporte le produit de
l'impôt sur les sociétés à tout le
bénéfice d'entreprises le bo calculé par
l'insee entreprises plus bas on est à
8,6 pour cent
donc tout ça c'est beaucoup un rideau de
fumée
parce que effectivement les peuples
proteste est-ce qu'il suffit maintenant
de taxes et des multinationales
bien sûr que non
la protestation des peuples c'est sur ce
que font les multinationales c'est sur
ce qu'elles font les recherches que n'a
pas engagé sanofi par exemple la
prédation de nos données personnelles
donc les recherches les investissements
qu'elle engage le démolition de l'emploi
donc la question de la gestion des
entreprises de d'une maîtrise nouvelle
désormais l'outil national c'est ça qui
est posée dans notre société et ont
dévié le coup en l'amenant sur on va
taxer et une fois qu'elles seront taxés
à ce compte il faudra bien faire mais
l'écologie l'emploi les biens communs la
santé sont des grandes questions
il s'agit pas de taper sur les
multinationales mais d'abord ceux des
travailleurs les multinationales c'est
pas que le capital bien loin de là et
ils ont beaucoup d'idées depuis
l'ouvrier jusqu'aux caves en passant par
les chercheurs
les techniciens et donc il se pose la
question d'autres pouvoirs d'instruments
commun pour co produire autrement et
décidé autrement ce qu'on produit
c'est ça la grande question et lb ça
pose effectivement des questions un
petit peu plus profonde sur les pouvoirs
il faut une autre logique que le capital
lé débat se focalise aujourd'hui sur ce
taux d'imposition mais un ce qu'il est
question aussi de ce qu'on fera aussi d'
du liant annassers une fois l'imposent
l'impôt mondial récupérée philippe
lauraire ans ce taux de 15 % juste pour
revenir ça ça ne concerne que les
multinationales qui font des bénéfices
exceptionnels c'est-à-dire des bénéfices
supérieure à 10% du chiffre d'affaires
donc amazon par exemple en est exclue
voulait rappeler donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très très faible et qui
pourra être contournée très probablement
facilement après 4 milliards d'euros
vous savez c'est une goutte d'eau dans
le budget français malheureusement ce
qu'il faudrait faire ces rapatriés
récupérer les 81 milliard d'évasion
fiscale ce qui est tout à fait possible
de fraude fiscale
moi je pense que très clairement il faut
une moralisation très forte du milieu
des affaires où il ya un problème grave
c'est quentin quelqu'un vole 5000 euros
offert un cambriolage ils forment prison
pour moi quand il ya de la fraude
fiscale de façon délibérée il doit y
avoir aussi la prison pour les
dirigeants de multinationales qui le
font dans la réforme repose également
sur un autre pilier une répartition plus
équitable des bénéfices et des droits
d'imposition entre pays concrètement
frédéric boccara c'est la possibilité de
pouvoir taxer les entreprises là où
elles font des profits et pas seulement
dans le pays où elles sont domicilés
combien d'entreprises sont concernées
dans le monde
or comme le dit philippe noiret en fait
ces quelques entreprises et quelques
multinationales plus exactement et
beaucoup de sociétés partout elles ont
des milliers de sociétés nées ces
quelques entreprises alors on sait pas
très bien ce que ça veut dire de dire là
où elles font du profit c'est toujours
très compliqué mais il ya aussi là où
elles produisent on peut pas seulement
dire il ya des travailleurs je me
permets de rappeler vous même d'ailleurs
vous travaillez philippe leur travail
lâche travail et c'est lé travail en
pagne de general electric qui font les
turbines à gaz qui travaille chez
central pour le hydroélectriques
ils font aussi du nucléaire c'est un qui
développe aussi les services et les
productions
donc on va pas seulement taxe est là où
on va acheter une turbine à gaz mais il
ya aussi la richesse qui a été créée là
où les travailleurs produisent hors ya
tous les multis comment se fait
l'évasion fiscale il faut comprendre il
ya des richesses créées mais il ya une
prédation sur ses richesses créées par
ce qu'on dit qu'on va enlever un certain
nombre de choses par exemple on va être
une filiale en suisse ou dans un paradis
fiscal qui va dire mais vous ne payez à
moi chaque fois que vous utilisez la
marque mcdonald's ou la marque general
electric
vous ne payez les brevets donc il faut
d'autres règles cc c'est ça la question
qui est posée alors il y aura 2 3
milliards qui seront en plus peut-être
c'est même pas sûr parce que d'autres
choses ont diminué là vous avez raison
et là où pointent à juste titre le g20
et le g7 avant lui c'est cette question
de la dimension coopérative du monde et
la répartition
effectivement on doit travailler sur des
règles de répartition des charges et des
activités il faut une autre logique de
répartition des activités dans le monde
et d'investissement et de coproductions
donc tout ça va pas nous emmener très
loin
c'est vraiment une goutte d'eau là on
voit l'immensité des besoins aussi bien
pour des nouveaux transports que pour
des médicaments
cc c'est vraiment de la poudre aux yeux
et vous allez voir ce qui va se passer
c'est que je suis même pas sûr qu'on
aura les 4 milliard de plus certains
pays font de la résistance en trois pays
européens notamment l'irlande la hongrie
et l'estonie qui tiennent vie
yb le mans à leur politique fiscale
conciliante quelles conséquences de
cette réforme pour ces pays est ce que
ça ça peut créer un appel d'air philippe
muller en fait ces pays il faut savoir
vivre vraiment de l'est de la fraude
fiscale des autres pays et du pillage
des rentes des recettes fiscales des
autres pays le luxembourg s'il n'ya plus
la fraude fiscale il ya 50 % du pib du
pays au moins qui disparaît donc ces
permis par l'union européenne puisque
par exemple mcdonald's a été condamné
par la justice française pour avoir
siphonné tous les résultats de la france
comme l'expliquait bien frédéric boccara
paul et siphonné vers le luxembourg si
je me rappelle bien est en fait la cour
de justice de l'union européenne l'a
protégé a priori l'union européenne ne
sanctionne pas il laisse faire la fraude
fiscale je pense qu'elle va pas se
mettre en désaccord avec les paradis
fiscaux européens qui sont quand même
très nombreux il ya l'irlande ya
luxembourg yamal qui a les pays bas il y
en a beaucoup
il y en a moins six ou sept et donc je
pense qu'ils ont quand même bouger pour
ne pas avoir de problème pas avoir de
sujets et de problèmes suite à cette
réforme si elle va jusqu'au bout parce
que ce n'est pas encore fait qu'elle
aille jusqu'au bout et elle va entrer en
vigueur à 10 r à 2023 et ce que d'ici là
on peut redouter aussi que les
multinationales finalement ne trouve des
mécanismes pour contourner la taxe
frédéric boccara alors bien sûr il
suffit en réalité donc l'irlande par
exemple en irlande sont localisées les
brevets de microsoft donc c'est je crois
un tiers du pib diamant qui était
constitué de droits de brevets etc qui
sont prélevées sur les autres pays pour
les uns mais en réalité philippe muray
regardera ce que je dis pas ce que le
pib c'est la production mais c'est pas
leurs revenus du pays en réalité une
grande partie de tout ça ressort vers
les îles caïmans ou vers les états unis
où sont en plus mieux situer disons les
centres financiers ces multinationales
donc il ya tout un indé pompe aspirante
et refoulante l'évasion fiscale ça
consiste à mettre des points avec des
pompes aspirantes et refoulante et des
tuyaux et puis il ya des portes pour
contrôler ces tuyaux donc là
on a donc une grande question c'est
qu'effectivement ça peut très bien être
contournée il suffit d'un pays qui fait
de l'évasion fiscale il suffit d'un
paradis fiscal mais je rajouterais
encore je jouerai à tous sur ce que dit
fier pleurèrent c'est que la france
elle-même est aussi un paradis fiscal
parce que par exemple les brevets où on
a dit tout à l'heure que le les profits
bruts sont placés à 31 % en taux facial
et on arrive à 8,6 pour cent en réalité
mais notamment parce que les revenus des
brevets que touche sanofi ne sont taxées
qu'à 10%
donc c'est un paradis fiscal pour les
revenus des brevets - de l'irlande mais
à mais plus que d'autres donc tout ça
crée la complexité ce ne sont pas
exactement des règles qui sont adoptées
par le g20 mais ce soit un certain
nombre de principes qui va être très
compliqué de décliner mais la dernière
chose dont on ne parle pas ce sont les
banques qui sont le moyeu l'art ou la
plaque tournante de tout cela et à
partir des banques en leur interdisant
de faire des moins avec les paradis
fiscaux à partir de quelques pays et des
pays qui sont censés proclamer leur
action contre l'évasion fiscale
on pourrait faire beaucoup et puis il
faut les pousser à une autre logique
c'est à dire inciter à au développement
de production utile et efficace
enfin le défi climatique et les défis
sanitaires c'est bien plus que d'évasion
fiscale qu'il faut qu'il faut s'attaquer
c'est un autre type d'investissement
donc une paix plus que de la
pénalisation des incitations une autre
utilité publique et les salariés qui
sont dans ces entreprises la demande que
ça ça m'a donné un tout autre sens à
leur travail
après les confinements à tous derniers
mois avec vous philippe maurer s'est
effectivement par les banques comme
l'indiquait à l'instant très direct vos
cordes vocales ac pourra être mis un
terme à l'évasion fiscale
il faut les inclure dans ce processus
est ce que c'est possible
alors non ça sera pas possible elles
vont pas vouloir donc moi ce que je
pense que c'est la crise les dirigeants
qui font de la fraude fiscale délibéré
doivent aller en prison
mais si les banques et les avocats qui
les aides doivent aussi faire la prison
je pense que ça sera que par ça j'en ai
discuté par un ami avocat avec un ami
avocat fiscaliste il ya que cette
méthode qui permettra de faire respecter
les règles mais il faut voir aussi une
autre chose cet cette concurrence
fiscale partout sur la planète est liée
à la mondialisation et on n'y arrivera
pas dans la mondialisation il faut
démondialiser il faut revenir avec des
règles nationales à des états qui ont
les règles qui peuvent fixer les règles
de justice et les règles fiscales qu'ils
veulent et les faire appliquer c'est
comme ça par cette démondialisation
qu'on reviendra à plus de justice
fiscale pour moi merci beaucoup monsieur
d'avoir pris le temps de participer à
cet échange ale ce soir frédéric boccara
et fils muraire tous les deux
économistes
on aura l'occasion de poursuivre à
nouveau ce débat dans de prochaines
éditions merci beaucoup et à bientôt sur
rt france